des soldes d'été commencent ans le 15
juillet au lieu du 24 juin
une idée séduisante pour certains
commerces une nécessité pour les autres
les boutiques de prêt-à-porter espère
ainsi proposer plus longtemps une
collection rentrée juste avant le
confinement
on va pouvoir faire un petit peu plus de
marge un petit peu plus longtemps
on a déjà perdu deux mois d'activité
donc gagner des sous un petit peu plus
longtemps sur la saison donc plutôt
bonne nouvelle dans les rues du centre
ville
l'idée d'un report des soldes d'été les
consommateurs dijonnais de marbre j'ai
pas trop prude faire les soldes j'ai
déjà suffisamment débit donc je m'en
fiche actuelle moi je trouve déjà que
ces soldes et je pense que les essais
des liquides et fait tout ce qu'ils ont
dans les magasins quand on va dans les
magasins on trouve pas mal du tout le
moins des 50% moins 50 moins 40 - 30 %
dans les grandes enseignes les offres et
autres ventes privées ne manquent pas
d'ailleurs certains commerçants
indépendants s'ils plébiscitent le
report des sols demande que les
promotions soit encadré jusque là pour
eux c'est une question de survie ou en
février on a acheté pour 6 mois
d'accord pour la saison d'été on a tous
rentrés entre mi janvier et mi février
on a rentré dix mille paires on en avait
vendu je sais pas peut-être 500 au 15
mars
et là on a tout un stock on a tout payé
et si on les prend pas là maintenant à
taux plein eh ben c'est cesser la mort
avoir du temps pour écouler les stocks
et se remettre à flots avant les soldes
c'est le souhait des commerçants
reste à savoir si le gouvernement les
entendra